when the ukrainian-born oligarch mikhail
friedman bought athlon house in 2016 he
paid more than 80 million dollars for it
in cash he's now subject to
international sanctions in the european
union asset freezes and travel bans but
he's not for now at least facing
sanctions here in the uk meaning that
this huge property is still very much in
private hands a man described in the eu
as a close member of vladimir putin's
inner circle
al jazeera
unsurprisingly we weren't invited in
sorry
like many of russia's big business
tycoons with large investments in the uk
friedman the owner of russia's alpha
bank has rubbed shoulders with british
high society
but he's accused of having one foot in
the business world and the other in the
criminal world because of his membership
of putin's close inner circle of rich
men who made their fortune buying and
selling state assets after the collapse
of the soviet union they're allowed to
hold on to their wealth if they help
protect putin's
that's until russia's invasion of
ukraine and a tidal wave of
international sanctions the west's
weapon of choice but indecision over the
speed of sanctions in the uk could allow
some of putin's associates to get their
money out of the country before it's
frozen everybody is scrambling to move
assets sell things you know get their
loot
out of harm's way i fear that by the
time we get to sanctions here in the uk
a lot of the
assets will be gone
the past few days the uk's most famous
oligarch roman abramovich has been in a
hurry to sell off chelsea football club
after 19 years of ownership like
friedman abramovic has avoided british
sanctions so far
denying he has a seat at putin's table a
few more obvious signs of how entrenched
russian money is here in the british
capital the roman abramovich's
15-bedroom mansion on one of the most
expensive heavily guarded streets in
europe now apparently on the market for
200 million dollars
elsewhere france and germany have seized
two super yachts owned by oligarchs
alicia smartoff and igor sechin with at
least five other super yachts owned by
russian billionaires anchored or
cruising in the maldives a country that
doesn't have an extradition treaty with
the u.s
putin's money is on the move the british
government says there are legal reasons
for lag and sanctions being imposed to
make sure they're watertight against
legal challenges but top lawyers warn
those challenges may be few and far
between now we have a situation where
no lawyer in london
will
happily take on a case like that because
we will be criticized
by
government ministers we will be
identified by name in parliament
named and shamed and we will be
criticized in the press there's a reason
the british capital has been nicknamed
london grad allegedly used to launder
vast sums of illicit russian money an
era that could be coming to an end
but when it comes to sanctions the
government's been urged to keep up the
pace or risk softening the blow
never al jazeera london